you know these motivational posters that
say stuff like if you can dream it you
can be it well that's pretty similar to
the vibe of no man's sky which is if you
can see it you can go there every planet
is procedurally generated and so is the
stuff on it so this endless universe is
filled with endless possibilities and
it's so big that although technically
we're all sharing the same space will
never even run into each other you get
to explore this vast open space naming
planets and the creatures you come
across but be careful you don't freeze
to death or boil in your own suit just
like real exploration you could be
facing some serious consequences
depending on where you go you'll find
creatures and vegetation and hopefully
the meaning of life itself in a game
that's almost as big as the hype that
precedes it no man's sky is coming to
ps4 on August ninth in North America
August tense in Europe and PC worldwide
on the 12th so that's probably the main
thing on everybody's plate this week but
what if you're looking for something
else well how about blade ballet this is
an online or couch combat fighting game
with all sorts of various modes it's
even got a rocket League option that's
less shameless than that one on
overwatch and it actually looks kind of
fun and it's out on ps4 and PC starting
on the 9th but we're not done yet with
games you can play locally with friends
in brutal a procedurally generated
dungeon crawler constructed from a ski
you can share loot you can level up and
you can fight together on various floors
of the dungeon that is until you descend
to floor 26 that's where you faced off
against the big bad guardian of the
dungeon and you got to get his crown all
the stuff you get isn't shared so if you
find an axe you better give it to the
best person for the job and if you throw
a potion in battle don't miss you can
heal your enemy just like you would a
friend there's also a level editor so
there's lots of replayability in this
dungeon crawler if
you're so inclined blade ballet is out
on pc and ps4 on the knife if you're
looking for a zen driving game look no
further than absolute drift Zen edition
so Zen there's an aerial view that gives
you the perfect perspective to smoothly
go where other cars have gone before
just not as smoothly there's more than
30 tracks six customizable cars and a
simplistic but elegant open world for
you to explore so consider downloading
this on your ps4 on the 10th finally if
you're a fan of Kingdom like I am you're
probably excited to learn they've
expanded on the content while keeping
the gameplay super clean and streamlined
but if you've never heard of this game
before let me tell you a tale you're a
king or a queen depending on your
preference and you're basically giving
money to stranger so they can join your
crazy cult and do stuff that earns you
money and then you can go out and get
more cult members with more money and
build a bigger Kingdom and then you ride
your cute horse into the woods but be
careful because there's dangers in there
and you gotta have protection from the
monster so you build walls and then the
coin sound good when you buy stuff this
game so much fun I really think you'll
like it the expansion comes out on the
9th and if you guys have never played it
before I definitely recommend a try and
that's all i have for you this week
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and sometimes they
change I'd say I'll see a no man's sky
but considering how big it is I don't
think we'll ever cross paths I hope you
guys enjoy it I'll see you again next
week